you know our students are calling out
and asking for help against magga
extremists who are threatening them
literally threatening them and sadly the
actions of some of the board majorities
in our state are leading to violence
against uh those uh who are in the lgbtq
plus Community as the bo order this is
not your meeting you may have a seat CU
if I did that to you in Sacramento you
would not accept it please sit I got a
point of order you're not going to
Blackmail us you not you'll not bully us
here in Chino please seek
[Applause]
in Chino we're going to take a 5 minute
break chaos in Chino as the state
superintendent of Public Instruction is
escorted out of the public meeting of
the Board of Education um but what I saw
here tonight was just catering to a mob
mentality it's controversial to know if
your kid is being secretly taught that
they're a girl if they're actually boy
that's not that should not be
controversial